ein anknüpfungspunkt ist gerhard flowers
aussage es gibt nicht daten doch würde
ich sagen es gibt daten das ist eine der
these die ich jetzt einfach mal in den
raum stellen möchte er zu beginn
weil ich in meinem vortrag versuche die
geister die geschichtswissenschaften so
ein bisschen zu charakterisieren und zu
zeigen
zu zeichnen das ist jetzt im anschluss
an ihren vortrag allerdings mit der
perspektive des dass der historikerin in
der zukunft die zweite ist anknüpfung
eigentlich auch an die vorigen vorträge
wir haben immer so ein bisschen
diskutiert auch über den gegenstand der
geisteswissenschaften aber auch über die
methode der geisteswissenschaften ich
versuche dass beide so ein bisschen doch
hier mit zu berücksichtigen
erst über die gegenstände und komme dann
zur methode zu sprechen weil ich
drittens sagen muss ich bin kein
theoretiker titel human ist dann
sicherlich sehr im bereich der methoden
verankert vor allen dingen zeit nicht
selber aber er ist praxis mensch ist
pragmatischer mensch und so ist der
beitrag auch zu sehen und ich hoffe dass
aus pragmatischen herangehensweise dann
vielleicht auch wieder ideen entstehen
die auf die theorie dann wieder zurück
zu führen sind beziehungsweise auch
helfen die theoretischen fragen die ihr
auch gestellt wurden sind in der tagung
zu beantworten
die ich beginne mit drei fallbeispielen
ich sagte ich versuche mal so ein
bisschen über den gegenstand mich zu
nähern
die sind alle durchaus bewusst gewählt
die stehen nicht in einer zwingenden
reihe aber sie behandeln alle so ein
bisschen das thema politische
provokation und die protagonisten ich
sage jetzt bewusst die stehen nicht in
irgend einer reihe sind von mir aus
pragmatischen gründen gewählt sind
bismarck goebbels und tram und
ich sage ich bin mit methodischer und
ich gucke halt was das jetzt aus dem
blickwinkel der geschichtsforschung das
vielleicht damit die methodisch
verbindende klammer unter dem motto
kontinuität und wandel
wir sehen dann auch so ein bisschen in
den drei beispielen die
unterschiedlichen medien die hier
eingesetzt werden
presse rundfunk und internet also durch
ein bisschen die die mediengeschichte
die sich hier wider spiegelt der
dahinter liegende zeitgeist und
letztlich auch die geschwindigkeit von
kommunikation
das erste beispiel ist die emser
depesche
ich denke der historische hintergrund
dürfte ihnen bekannt sein es ging damals
um die zwei fragen die konkurrenz um die
vorherrschaft in europa zwischen
frankreich und preußen nach der gründung
des norddeutschen bundes 1867 und dann
der sehr konkrete anlass der streit um
den verzicht des hauses hohenzollern auf
die spanische thronfolge nach der
absetzung tabelle als zweiter der 2
zwei jahre zuvor 1868 grundlage der
folgenden öffentlichen provokation ist
dann die audienz des französischen
gesandten benedetti beim preußischen
könig wilhelm und 13
juli 1870 in bad ems dem bericht darüber
nimmt dann der bismarck vertraute
heinrich abend vor und telegrafierte
nach berlin
bismarck redigiert dieses ursprünglich
interne und in einem doch möchte man
sagen sachlich diplomatischen
konzilianten ton verfasste protokoll
stark so dass sich der tenor des
gespräches eben nicht mehr konziliant
sondern stoff ist beleidigend darstellte
bismarck lancierte dann dieses dokument
an die presse es wird dann für durch die
französische übersetzung noch ein
bisschen noch weiter verschärft gelangt
in die französische öffentlichkeit und
sorgte für die wohl von bismarck
erhoffte provokation und empörung in der
öffentlichkeit
historiker bewerten diese aktion dann in
der tat als eine bewusste provokation
bismarcks die frankreich letztlich nur
die wahl zwischen krieg und politischer
niederlage ließen
und in der tat wenige tage später am 19
juli erfolgte die französische
kriegserklärung in der raschen folge
dann die niederlage frankreichs und
auch in der konsequenz dann die gründung
des deutschen kaiserreiches
das ist das erste beispiel ich stelle
diese drei beispiele einfach einmal vor
und werde dann später dann wieder darauf
zurückgreifen das zweite beispiel ist
die sogenannte sportpalastrede das heißt
die rede die josef gorbitz der wurde
heute schon mal kurz thematisiert am 18
februar 1943 im berliner sportpalast
hielt mit seinen sehr leider sehr
berühmt gewordenen rhetorischen fragen
wie wollt ihr den totalen krieg und so
weiter
diese sportpalastrede geht nach peter
longerich als besonders perfides
musterbeispiel nationalsozialistischer
propaganda und rhetorik und nicht nur
das sondern mit der rede selbst
inszenierte sich goebbels goebbels
inszenierte sich selbst als auf jeder
langericht auf peitsche einer kriegs
begeisterten deutschen volksgemeinschaft
die rede soll und nun als beispiel
dienen für eine politisch motivierte
massenkommunikation dann gezielt diese
rede nicht nur vor 15.000 sorgfältig
ausgewählten und choreografisch
instruierten claqueuren vor ort sondern
sie wurde auch über radio übertragen für
die wochenshow aufgezeichnet und
international wahrgenommen
natürlich ist die rede gegenstand
historischer untersuchungen geworden und
jetzt sind wir so ein paar beispiele für
auch letztlich deutung fragen historiker
diskutieren ob sie diese rede etwa eine
reaktion des ns-regimes auch die
konferenz der alliierten in casablanca
vierundzwanzigster januar gewesen ist wo
ihr die formulierung einer
bedingungslosen kapitulation als
kriegsziel erfolgte oder war es doch
eher und das ist wohl das
wahrscheinlichere eine reaktion auf die
verheerenden niederlage der deutschen
truppen bei stalingrad wenige wochen
zuvor
zugleich wird etwa diskutiert und das
ist wieder peter longerich ob es hier um
ein profilierungsversuch goebbels sich
handelt ein versuch durch eine
radikalisierung des regimes selbst die
in politische führung zu übernehmen
rechts sehen sie dann auch bild ein
beispiel für eine internationale
reaktion die erfolgte dann ein jahr
später aber flugblätter der us airforce
im rahmen ihrer psychologischen
kriegsführung und im rahmen dieser
flugblätter wurden dann die deutsche
bevölkerung zum widerstand gegen das
regime aufgerufen
wie gesagt ich sehe diese beispiele
nicht in einer inhaltlichen folge oder
in einen inhaltlichen zusammenhang ich
möchte auch nicht die beiden akteure
miteinander vergleichen das verbietet
sich aber die beiden beispielen sei
dennoch gemeinsam unterstellt dass beide
eine öffentlichkeit die öffentlichkeit
nutzende die öffentlichkeit gar
instrumentalisieren politische
diplomatische provokation darstellen
beiden akteuren ist dabei gemein dass
sie die ihnen damals zur verfügung
stehenden medien presse radio hierfür
gezielt und zumindest im falle der emser
depesche ausgesprochen effektiv
einsetzen und diese beispiele aus der
vergangenheit sind eben heute gegenstand
historischer forschung
wenn nun in die gegenwart gucken gucken
tue ich das weil diese heutige gegenwart
die vergangenheit künftige historiker
generationen sein wird wir hatten schon
gehört die e mail hat lange in den
deutschen behörden einzug gehalten in
deutschland ab 184 zuerst die e mail
aufgetaucht
im kontext der elektrifizierung der
behörden so genannte electronic
government wird sie dann eben auch
später vielleicht auch schon jetzt aber
dann in naher zukunft gegenstand
historischer forschung werden zumindest
und zu quellen der der zeitgeschichte
heute schon aber in der zukunft
natürlich noch viel stärker ich möchte
einen schritt weiter gehen über diese e
mail hinaus und eben dieser andere
kommunikationsformen die sie hier sehen
kurz darüber sprechen
sie halt auch von manchen politikern der
gegenwart momentan gewählt werden und
dieses beispiel dow jones kann insofern
in die eu aufgenommen werden als dass
auch er dass ihm zeitgemäß erscheinende
und zeitgemäß zur verfügung stehende
medium gezielt einsetzt mindestens eben
um eben politisch zu provozieren und
bismarck und es ist auch interessant zu
sehen die selbe sagte pasche depesche
funktionierte deswegen auch als
politische provokation so gut weil sie
der text sehr kurz war und jump
reduziert das ganze jetzt auf die 140
bzw 280 zeichen von twitter die ihnen
bequem ausreichend für seine
kommunikation zu seiner bewertung
schreibt jetzt beispielsweise hillary
clinton
sie ignoriere die meisten tweets des
präsidenten sich fügt dann aber hinzu
the most dangerous thing she does
erstkontakt diplomacy und twitter ist
trading in swift kim jong-un which is
just like that vorher sein gefundenes
fressen
und da sind wir dann auch wieder bei der
deutung frage welche wirkungen jump mit
solcher politischen provokationen
tatsächlich erreicht es wird dann
sicherlich auch von künftigen
historikern zu bewerten seien und
künftige historiker so sehr zu vermuten
werden als historische quellen
betrachten und sich diesen entsprechend
nähern unter welchen rahmenbedingungen
das ganze dann geschehen kann da werde
ich dann noch darauf zu sprechen kommen
die drei beispiele sollen nun also ein
neuartige digitale quellen in ihrem
historischen kontext heranführen
neuartig möchte ich in den kontext
wirklich social media benennen da dies
kommunikationsformen darstellen die wir
so bislang noch nicht kannten tweets
sind titel born sind eben anders als
digitalisierte quellen letztere
existieren ursprünglich in anderer form
die hatte das papier der in die presche
was wir gesehen haben wurden durch retro
digitalisierung in ein digitales sogar
überführt digitalisierte quellen sagen
wir heute auch schon diskutiert werden
selbstverständlich heute von historikern
herangezogen schon rein aus gründen der
arbeitseffizienz da haben wir eben auch
schon zugehört für die anwendung
computergestützte verfahren von dem
gerhard lauer so sehr schön berichtet
hat im kontext einer digital humanities
oder einer digital history sind sie
eigentlich eine conditio sine qua non
als digital bahndaten sind sie für
historiker wird anders als für
sozialwissenschaftler die sich social
media natürlich sehr ausführlich jetzt
in der gegenwart beschäftigen er für
historiker er neu was einfach darin
begründet ist dass historiker eine
gewisse zeitliche distanz zu ihrem
untersuchungsgegenstand aufbauen muss
und das haben wir auch mehrfach
diskutiert im rahmen dieser tage die
fans von tweets von trump möchte ich
diesen kontext so dass dieser begründung
heraus in eben dieser reihe der emser
depesche und der sportpalastrede sehen
als untersuchungsgegenstände und das
möchte ich zu
vom gegenstand zur methode wechseln
denn wenn wir solche quellen als quelle
künftiger historiker akzeptieren müsste
man sich gedanken darüber machen über
ihre rolle im forschungs- und
erkenntnisprozess der historiker die
folgende überlegungen fußen jetzt auf
einen eher traditionelle sichtweise
eines dreiklangs einer historischen
methode die beginnt dann so in der
göttinger schule des 18 jahrhunderts
dass sie angelegt und der wäre es dann
so richtig verankert fest verankert ist
dann 1957 in seiner historisch der sagt
das wesen der historischen methode sei
es forschung vorstand zu verstehen das
sei die interpretation und sichert eben
das was er unter seiner historic
versteht methodisch ab bei ihnen sind es
dann vor allen dingen drei bestandteilen
an der historischen methodik das ist
wesentlichen bekannt sicherlich erstens
das suchen die heuristik zweitens die
quellenkritik und drittens das
beurteilen verstehen und interpretieren
und ich hatte gestern in einer rückfrage
also ein bisschen versucht zu
unterscheiden zwischen befund und
deutung ich würde auch hier diese
unterscheidung sehen befund und deutung
kommt da gleich auch noch darauf zu
sprechen
bei der quellen kritik steht sieht
reusen verschiedene themen oder
verschiedene fragestellungen die dazu
beantworten sind erstens die kritik der
echtheit zweitens die frage nach der
richtigkeit und drittens die kritik des
früheren und später dann ich werde das
gleich an einem anderen beispiel dann
aufgreifen und hier noch ein zweiter
gewährsmann nennen für diese
quellenkritik nämlich ernst bernheim der
das dann später auch aufgreift und ein
bisschen anders differenziert in äußere
und innere quellenkritik mir ist dabei
insbesondere die äußere quellenkritik
wichtig weil in der folge beispiel werde
ich darauf eingehen wie sich für eine
künftige geschichtswissenschaftler
dieser äußere quellenkritik in eine
technische quellenkritik wandeln müssen
das fallbeispiel was ich jetzt
heranführen möchte ist ein relativ
aktuelles auch sie erinnern sich
vielleicht nachdem die
koalitionsvereinbarung verhandeln
gescheitert sind zwanzigster november
1900 2017 dass die fdp-führung diesem
twitter veröffentlicht hat dass das ein
tweet mit einem bild lieber nicht
regieren als falsch und ich möchte jetzt
das man nutzen und mal die leitfragen
die ernst bernhard schön formuliert hat
zu den äußeren quellenkritik mal kurz
kursorisch daran abarbeiten
bernhard schreibt erstens entspricht die
äußere form der quelle der form die den
als echt bekannten sonstigen quellen
derselben art zurzeit und am ort der
angeblichen beziehungsweise angenommenen
entstehung unserer quelle eigen ist
würde sagen ja durchaus tweet sieht eben
wenn er bildhaft ist der sieht ebenso
aus zweitens entspricht der inhalt der
quelle dem was uns sonst aus sicher
echten quellen bekannt ist ja tut sie
der inhalt entspricht der
presseerklärung der fdp von von lindner
und auch dem auftritt von fernsehen das
wissen wir in der gegenwart künftige
historiker werden dass daran bemessen
können was eben dann auch an
pressemitteilung in tageszeitungen
fernsehaufzeichnungen und so der zukunft
erhalten bleibt
drittens entsprechend form und inhalt
dem charakter und mit ganzen milieu der
entwicklung innerhalb derer die quelle
angeblich steht ja im vergleich etwa die
wahlkampfplakate oben rechts im bild der
gegenwart der tweet erhält enthält ein
bild im gleichen stil auch hier
natürlich voraussetzung für die
künftigen historiker dass diese wahl
plakate oder fotos von den wahlplakaten
auch überliefert werden
vierter finden sich in oder an der
quelle spuren künstlicher fälschen mache
wie etwa unglaubwürdige seltsame art der
auffindung und übermittelung divison
stoppt hier stellt sich nämlich die
frage wie ist das eigentlich
festzustellen augenscheinlich erst mal
nichts was uns ungewöhnlich erscheint
oder unglaubwürdig text immanent ist da
eigentlich nichts festzustellen und ein
material wie wir es jetzt bei der
aufdeckung etwa der gefälschten
hitler-tagebücher hatte das war ja die
eines der entscheidenden kriterien
dieses dieses papier untersuchung die ja
dann aufgedeckt hat dass er
offensichtlich eine ganze reihe von
prominenten historikern ihren gesunden
menschenverstand ausgeschaltet hatte was
daneben die materielle untersuchungen
letztlich dann auch ein doch
einschlägigen weiß für die fälschung
geliefert hat so was gibt es hier
zunächst mal nicht das ist ja im
materiellen das ist ja im digitalen aber
wenn man da mal hinguckt und das ist
jetzt ein bisschen schlecht zu sehen
gibt es mal versucht ein bisschen
einzubringen dann sehen sie rechts neben
diesem tweet ein paar informationen
nämlich zunächst oben über dieses brot
zwanzigster 11 2007
das ist das datum an dem dieser tweet
veröffentlicht wird dass speicher
twitter somit und da kommt manchmal
drunter das ist eine bilddatei die wurde
dabei twitter hochgeladen sind bilddatei
hat einen namen und der wird mit
transportiert und da sieht man wenn man
da genau hin trug das schiff 17 11 16
für alle die in computern zu tun haben
die wissen dass es typischen verfahren
wie man dateien mit einem datum stack
versieht ja monat tag kann man das
besonders gut diskutieren
besonders entscheiden besonders gut
sortieren und 17 11 16 steht sehr
wahrscheinlich für 2017 11 november 16 4
tage bevor das ganze veröffentlicht
wurde
die haben wir also ein meter datum ist
das ja hier ist und ein indiz letztlich
für den entstehungszeitpunkt dieses bild
ist vier tage bevor es veröffentlicht
wurde
zu diesem zeitpunkt liefen die
verhandlungen natürlich das ergebnis der
quellenkritik könnte also lauten das
bild wurde drei tage oder 4 tage vor
dessen veröffentlichung er stellt deuten
und befunde deuten könnte man das dann
so das ganze war ein vorbereiteter coup
die verhandlungen sollten bewusst zum
platzen gebracht wurde und das ist genau
diese das bashing was dann auch die fdp
dann an diesem tag dann auch nieder
er prallte so wird es dann in der
öffentlichkeit dargestellt dass
zitat von klaus arnold in seinem abriss
über die quellenkritik der sagt die
quellenkritik darf in keinem fall eine
solche interpretation immer nennt das
heißt allein aus dem text heraus und
ohne vorherige möglichst weitgehende
recherche über die faktischen
hintergründe und und die umstände seiner
entstehung verfolgen und das gilt auch
hier doch ein zukünftiger historiker
sollte das bittere herzen denn die
quellenkritik zum herstellungsdatum ist
nun richtig die interpretation aber voll
voreilig und der befund reicht an dieser
stelle nicht aus denn zur wirklichen
beurteilung ist die quellenlage bislang
nicht ausreichend
und hier hat dann die fdp selbst das
geliefert das ist es unten rechts
was künftig und gründliche historiker
dann aus dem archiv natürlich ausgraben
müssen aber da stehen sie eben da dass
sie drei für die verschiedenen szenarien
des ausgangs der koalitionsverhandlungen
das ganze entsprechend vorbereitet haben
wenn wir also das jetzt ausblenden
würden dann künftige historiker hätten
werden muss das problem hier verursacht
und hier möchte ich an der stelle eine
kleine fußnote zu dem begriff exaktheit
dann haben wir uns heute ja auch drüber
unterhalten einfügen noch ein bisschen
den begriff exakt hat in frage stellen
wenn man kann sehr exakt diese sache und
die sachen hier bestimmen und kann
genauso exakt das alles ausziehen
die zählung ist sehr sehr exakt aber die
fragen sie mal was sagt das zu zählende
oder das eben formalisiert explizit
beschriebenen dann tatsächlich über den
gegenstand aus und das ist ein problem
der heuristik letzten nicht dass man das
natürlich dann zu dieser exakten
wissenschaft hinzuzählen muss und da ist
glaube ich in den digitalen
geisteswissenschaften momentan noch so
ein gewisser gap dass diese beiden
sachen noch nicht so richtig
zusammenpassen
das ist wo die das studium energies als
methodische wissenschaft noch glaube ich
sehr daran zu arbeiten hat und sich sehr
genau überlegen muss wie man diese
diesen keppler überbrücken kann so
valide interpretationen das
abzuschließen für unserer historiker der
zukunft müsste also lauten um eine
schnelle öffentlichkeit zu ermöglichen
wurden verschiedene szenarien von langer
hand vorbereitet
eine schlussfolgerung jetzt für die
arbeit der historiker würde sagen würde
lauten auch digitale quellen können und
müssen mit quellen kritischer methodik
gründlichkeit beruhigt werden
zum zweiten ist aber dass diese methodik
selbst zunehmend technisch digital wird
denn das auffinden von solchen
technischen metadaten die in diesem
beispiel funktioniert meistens dann nur
mit einem mit technisch digitalen
methoden selbst mit einem entsprechenden
sachverstand und das ist eine der
aufgabenfelder der del-historie digital
humanities an der stelle das gesagte
gilt dann weiterhin auch für die kritik
der echtheit fälschungen sind natürlich
keine erfindung der gegenwart
zahlreicher historiker haben sich etwa
mit den fälschungen aus dem mittelalter
beschäftigt als punkt vielleicht
prominentestes beispiel die constantin
ische schenkung mithilfe fototechnische
retuschen beginnt man dann einen frühen
zwanzigsten jahrhundert und das ganze
bildquellen kannst du damit linien
stalin spd treiben das richtig richtig
weit
es kommt dann heute im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert allerdings auch die
fälschung des audiovisuellen hinzu und
kennen sich vielleicht unter dem
schlagwort die fake das ist also eine
zunächst eine originale aufnahme von
barack obama wie eine ansprache oder
eine rede hält was wir hier rechts sehen
dass ein schauspieler sind
stimmenimitator von obama der spricht
jetzt etwas ganz anderes in dem beispiel
zusätzlich obama relativ unfertig und
unproblematisch über die politik scheint
und das liegt er ihn im mund in den bund
im wahrsten sinne des wortes denn durch
die entsprechende methodik dass das
triebwerk wird das hier ausgeschnitten
und dann dem dem obama also wie lippen
die lippen bewegung und der ton dazu
wird ihm auf diese weise auch technisch
in den mund gelegt ich glaube dass man
durch fälschungen sehr viele
erkenntnisse über die vergangenheit
gewinnen kann durch fälschungen als ich
das falsch gesagte ebenso wie auch das
nicht nicht gesagt nicht nur über den
fälscher sondern auch intentionen über
politik und herrschaft um das aber zu
können muss das gefälschte als solches
erkannte von der nicht fälschung
unterschieden werden des diskriminiert
weil sie es wurde heute thematisiert und
zum zentralen element der quellenkritik
kritik geworden
fälschungen selbst waren technisch
eigentlich immer recht aufwändig
zumindest wenn sie gut sein sollten
erforderten dort gewisse versiertheit
aber ebenso erforderte an deren
aufklärung auch entsprechende versierte
kenntnisse und fertigkeiten denen sich
die geisteswissenschaftler war
eigentlich auch schon bei dem sich die
geisteswissenschaftler eigentlich auch
schon immer den methoden der
naturwissenschaften bedienter die
materialforschung c13 methode usw
was dann im platzierungsverfahren fragen
für echtheits fragen mal herangezogen
werden
was heute ein bisschen andere qualität
bekommt ist das spiel scheinbar leichter
zu machen sind und auch schneller in den
umlauf gebracht werden können noch mal
zurück zu dem beispiel die schwierigkeit
mit solchen dingen dann umzugehen wird
allerdings in der zukunft erhalten
bleiben in der zukunft wird uns dann
sicherlich auch erhalten bleiben aus
solchen fälschungen dann vielleicht auch
mehr zu lesen außer das ist ein feld
gefälschtes objektes sondern auch was
dann letztlich dahinter steht eigentlich
hinter dieser fälschungs absicht
beim jetzt neun gedanken noch versuchen
an der stelle uns wieder das digitale
bewegen in die web publikationen nicht
nur bei publikationen social media
einerseits aber auch andere formen der
web publikationen etwa eine
kommentierung von zeitschriften
zeitungsartikel denken dann geht es
nicht mehr nur um die fälschung im
klassischen sinne
das ist das kämmen wäre weil sie sondern
auch um das erkennen dass unterscheiden
der menschlichen äußerungen von der
maschinellen also wissen dass großteil
von kommentaren im internet gar nicht
mehr von menschen verfasst werden
sondern bewusst maschinell auch
gesteuert werden um gewisse dinge zu
beeinflussen
das heißt wenn wir jetzt hier noch mal
hingucken bei diesen sachen das ist
sicherlich ein mensch noch weiter
reichen gibt es schon aber hier guck mal
das retweets gefällt mir angaben eine
immense zahlen hier und da kommen dann
ellenlange kommentare dann darunter
frage ist schon was ist da eigentlich
menschlich und was ist davon dann auch
maschinell erstellt und diese
unterscheidung zu treffen halte ich auch
dann für eine ganz wichtige das
elementar für das gewinnen von
erkenntnis aus eben diesen quellen und
auch diese unterscheidung kompetenz wird
zukünftig nur noch mit technischen
möglichkeiten zu erlangen sein
hier scheinen jetzt tatsächlich auch
italien schleiermacher plötzlich wieder
aktuell zu werden oder zumindest kann
man mit denen jetzt vielleicht mal
operieren denn ihre hermeneutik ist ja
eine hermeneutik der menschlichen
äußerungen und wir gewinnen jetzt sich
diese
automatische text generierung
möglicherweise eine neue form der
äußerung hinzu und kann man drei
stossrichtungen vielleicht künftig
diskutieren nicht stelle nur die fragen
reicht das als problem auf habe keine
antworten auf die frage erstens das
herausfiltern den menschlichen
äußerungen aus der gesamtheit also so
eine art touring testen hier angewandt
zweiter die maschine in äußerungen in
die hermeneutik einzubetten also quasi
teil der menschlichen äußerungen zu
verstehen das nicht als unmittelbare
sondern ist eine mittelbare äußerung
und drittens vielleicht die maschinen
selbst als akteure zu betrachten und
eine eigene hermeneutik zu entwickeln es
nicht ganz der begriff der digitalen und
hermeneutik von capo es geht hat eine
andere stoßrichtung es geht ja
eigentlich eher um die frage ist die
maschine objekt oder subjekt der
erneuten gleiche frage mal bei der ethik
stellen wenn man bei der algorithmen
algorithmen ethik ist da eigentlich das
technische das objekt oder wird das
nicht langsam selber auch bei autonomen
systemen zum subjekt und hier kann man
dann auch wieder gucken was wird da
nicht gesagt bei den gilt etwa dann mit
der mit der lebenserfahrung gesagt die
dieses verstehens große lebenserfahrung
heraus möglicher wie es beim
maschinellen äußerungen was habe ich
dafür eine für eine lebenserfahrung
eigentlich und kann die gleiche frage
auch umgekehrt stellen man kann fragen
wenn es um automatisierte prozesse gibt
die ja letztlich auch irgendwie dahin
trainiert werden sollen dass die
menschliche äußerungen verstehen können
dass maschinen überhaupt weil ihnen die
lebenserfahrung fehlt im kontext mit
sogenannter künstlicher intelligenz und
autonome systeme wird dies dann
zunehmend komplex auch hier sehe ich
dann die rolle der digital humanities
hier entsprechende methoden zu
entwickeln arnold sagt wieder mögliche
manipulierbarkeit durch durch technische
hilfsmittel schafft neue methodische
probleme also ich denke
werden neue methodische probleme für uns
in den digitalen geisteswissenschaften
geschaffen so jetzt möchte ich
fortgeschritten mit der zeit die
geschichte im digitalen zwar ein
bisschen jetzt zunächst die methodik in
der zukunft wird es natürlich ganz
andere quellen gattungen für künftige
historiker geben einfach zwei große
bereiche den einnahmen wir schon
gesprochen ist das herrschafts und
verwaltungstätigkeiten werden zunehmend
digital electronic government e mail in
der verwaltung usw
darüber haben wir schon gesprochen zwei
quellen aus dem nicht politischen
kontext und drittens dann vielleicht die
verschmelzung von beiden von dem nicht
von den politischen und dem nicht
politischen was man vielleicht ja noch
pars pro toto für eine gegenwärtige
verschmelzung oder entgrenzung vormals
vielleicht schärfer konturiert räume
sehen kann eben hier schreibt ein
politiker und das hier unten das ist
dann da nochmal politiker natürlich aber
die 180.000 reaktionen das sind nicht
alles politiker und das sind dann ist
dann eben nicht mehr im primär
politischen raum was hier stattfindet
auch früher haben selbstverständlich die
menschen auf medienäußerungen reagieren
können haben dies auch getan
sicherlich auch auf die presseberichte
über bad ems oder die
rundfunkübertragung der sportplatz
sportpalastrede was sie aber nicht
content früher war oder zumindest nur
sehr aufgewühlt auswendig und
eingeschränkte tun dies über genau die
gleichen medien zu tun also sozusagen
gleichrangig zu reagieren
geschweige denn innerhalb dieser medien
zu interagieren das ist die neue
komponente sicherlich bei der social
media während bad emstal dialog
charakter zunächst besaß mit wenigen
akteuren in der kommunikation zunächst
bei der götschen rede ist ist eine
unidirektionale broadcast kommunikations
gibt also einen sender goebbels zuhörer
im palast selbst und nicht teil der
inszenierung sind das programm selbst
und ein keine eigenständige akteure ihr
akzenten im sinne von natur
instrumentalisierte subjekte und
teilnehmen
dort cast und dann haben wir es anders
dritte die ich an wir haben hier das web
2.0 mit dem mitmach web das neuartige
konzept des präsidenten greift hier an
dieser stelle kommunikation erfolgt
nicht mehr bidirektional nicht
unidirektionale doch nicht sternförmig
sondern eigentlich unkontrolliert
zunächst netzartig automatisch
interaktiv wie kritische kommentierung
mike mills und so weiter
dass eine solche form der kommunikation
durchaus weitreichende konsequenzen
haben kann auch für die große politik
hat etwa die der arabische frühling 2011
gezeigt es ist eben eine ganze festwoche
mobilisierungen durch die social media
gegeben hat haben wir also nicht
vielleicht nicht die einzelne große
handlung wie bei der debatte etwa aber
sehr möglichst vieler kleiner handlungen
wie eben dieser mobilisierungen
[Musik]
ein zweiter arzt der entgrenzung die uns
auch neue quellen bescheren wird in der
zukunft ist die entgrenzung zwischen
privatem und öffentlichem raum ich
möchte ganz kurz ein anderes sprang
erinnern mit ihrem tagebuch
da kann man nicht von dem tagebuch
sprechen sondern es gibt wesentlichen
zwei versionen die aversion und die b
version die aversionen verfassung
schreibt anne frank für sich privat
intim und als sie den aufruf im radio
gehört hat dass die exil-regierung nach
dem krieg gerne kriegserinnerungen und
erinnerungen die besatzungszeit
veröffentlichen möchte gehen sie dann
dieses tagebuch umzuschreiben ihnen eine
veröffentlichte version wenn sie ganz
kurz gucken hier zwischen der erfassung
der befassung in einer textstelle die
unterscheiden sich teilweise signifikant
intimer fassung öffentlichkeit die
fassung
das jetzt ein bisschen vergleich somit
quellen die wir zur verfügung haben
heute die möglichkeiten der aus dass des
eigenen ausdrucks heute über das
internet
da kann man sich vorstellen dass diese
beiden bereiche verschmelzen könnten
facebook hat ja diesen mechanismus dinge
öffentlich zu machen oder nur im
freundeskreis oder in privat zu halten
man facebook als ein tagebuch betrachtet
dann könnte das genau
ein ähnliches phänomen später mal so zur
beobachtung 19 betrachtung bekommen wie
hier dieses tagebuch der anne frank
diese ganzen quellen kamen dann
allerdings momentan ein großes problem
für künftige historiker nehme ich das
ist die frage der archivierung
da hatten wir auch schon darüber
gesprochen denn wenn wir im heutigen
digitalen kommunikationsformen künftig
als historiker forschen können wollen
müssen wir heute gegenwärtig unsere
zukunft etwas hinterlassen damit das
dann überhaupt als quelle genutzt werden
kann
eine frank tagebuch
ist exzeptionell das ist eine der
wenigen überlieferung dieser form die
die waren haben man weiß ja auch nicht
wie viel gegeben hatten wir schon
vernichtet worden sind kein zufall sein
kein zufall zur unfall- und das heute
sicher gesichert hat damals aber
insgesamt dann doch eine von wenigen
überlieferung aus dieser zeit die emser
depesche etwa die sportpalastrede das
sind natürlich dann teilweise dinge die
bewusst aktiviert werden da gibt es die
entsprechenden institutionen dafür die
das tun können bei twitter ist das ein
bisschen social media ist das jetzt ein
bisschen anders die problemlage
wir haben natürlich bei twitter eine
immanente archivierung also ich das
technische system twitter selbst
problems nur das ist ja teil des
geschäftsmodells und twitter und es
bedarf sei theoretisch ist keiner
bewussten archivierung durch eine
institution eigentlich nur der
bereitstellung von technischem
arbeitstechnischen speicherplatz aber
trotzdem sich ein großes problem denn
die frage ist offen ob werden sehen 50
100 jahren überhaupt noch auf das
bildarchiv kurt werden zugreifen können
was passiert da eigentlich john street
das sind die äußerung einer person
person öffentlichen interesses und das
bundesarchiv muss natürlich jetzt sich
dieser aufgabe stellen diese sachen zu
archivieren
aber was passiert mit diesen ganzen
retweets und dieser kommunikation die da
hinten dran steht wie gehen wir
eigentlich damit um und machen wir uns
eigentlich nicht gegenwertes begeben wir
uns nicht gegenwärtig für künftige
historiker eigentlich eine doch fatale
abhängigkeit privaten zu privaten
unternehmen indem wir unsere
kommunikation und unsere äußerungen die
gegenstand der hermeneutik oder der
deutung dann später auch sein sollen
indem wir eben diesen privaten
unternehmen übergeben wo noch überhaupt
nicht klar ist wie so was eigentlich
dann später geregelt werden kann es ist
eine große aufgabe momentan es geht
nicht nur um die sicherung von
forschungsdaten es geht nicht nur um die
langfristige speicherung der ganzen
digitalisate die wir
produzieren sondern es geht insbesondere
um die sicherstellung der quellen
künftige historiker generationen nicht
umsonst spricht man für die frühzeit des
internationen internet dark ages
durchaus ein ganz wichtiger aspekt und
das ist jetzt bereich den ich ganz
kurzen anreise nimmt den überspringe ich
jetzt es ist ja auch nicht damit getan
dass man einmal etwas abspeichert
sondern das internet ist der ist ja
fluide und websites und so weiter die
verändern sich im laufe der zwei
teilweise relativ schnell eine web
archivierung muss an die sehr schnelle
sehr kurze zeit schnitte vornehmen um
die sachen zu archivieren sondern sind
die einfach weg und da ist glaube ich
jetzt auch schon enorm viel weg und
deswegen unglaublich ist der begriff des
da der dark ages an der stelle durchaus
angebracht ich möchte abschließend mit
einigen wenigen gedanken jetzt auch zu
diesem der leitfrage dieser tage nämlich
wechselspiel was ist
geisteswissenschaftler gehe ich nicht
drauf ein
aber geisteswissenschaften
naturwissenschaften und ich möchte das
auch noch mal aus dieser perspektive der
historischen arbeitsweise tun wenn wir
das jetzt mal so als eine dialektik
auffassen und mal den preußen so als
eine these formulieren dann sieht sich
der mit zahlreichen anti thesen
eigentlich gegenüber gestellt hat mir
sehr viel forschen schon von gehört
betroffen sind natürlich die ganze story
demografisch ausgerichtet es kommen die
ganzen prothetischen die ganzen
neumodischen ansätze quasi als die nach
den gesetzmäßigkeiten der geschichte
schauen als antithese den positivismus
finden wir das in den historischen
materialismus und strukturalismus da
haben wir schon viel viel von gehört
eine andere these antithese könnte sein
dass sie diskutiert und hermeneutik
versus distant reading erneut dann er
aus dieser klassischen sichtweisen es
kommt dann eben so ein listing widing
sozusagen als eine antithese dagegen
hinzu kommen auch das was ich versucht
hatte anzudeuten nämlich die erweiterung
der quellenlage aus der sich
eine erweiterung der fragestellung für
den flieger historiker ergeben wird und
das sind jetzt wieder bei den titel
humanities denn ich denke eigentlich
kann die diplomatie ist genau die
benötigte synthese hier in der stelle
blicken schon für eine idee grafische
geschichtsschreibung wird gelten in der
zukunft zumindest die können wir
eigentlich relevante daten überhaupt
finden ohne computergestützte verfahren
also das was man als information
retrieval bezeichnet er wird auch teil
einer methodik sein die wirklich
traditionell so auf video grafische
untersuchungen ausgerichtet sein soll
sein wird aber wenn es dann weiter geht
und man schaut hier bei diesen 184000
nah wie viele es waren
retweets bewährt das eigentlich wie
bietet da geht es nicht mehr um den
einzelfall sondern da geht es dann um
die erfassung von struktur ist werden
diese mode ethische wo ich denke dass
das schon gegenwärtig durch die sozialen
politikwissenschaften ein gegenstand der
ihrer forschung ist wenn es etwa um die
rolle der social media im arabischen
frühling gegangen ist dafür braucht es
dann quantitative verfahren
computergestützte verfahren die ihm auch
die digital humanities bieten und dafür
braucht man dann belastbare daten dafür
und daten werden künftige historiker
omas haben wenn es uns gelingt diese
sachen ausreichend zu archivieren
die entscheidende frage dabei ist aber
das hatte ich auch schon angedeutet ob
die daten für die jeweilige
fragestellung wirklich belastbar sind
und das würde ich gerne als eine frage
der quellenkritik verstehen
das muss dann sozusagen eine
verheiratung von einem historiker
schencking dass du jetzt noch mal ein
anderer begriff den man hier heranführen
kann der quellenkritik und des
computational thinking der des data
science der datenanalyse
eine freileitung geben müssen und diese
beiden müssen aufeinander abgestimmt
werden
man kann das ganze etwas plakativer
formulieren man kann sagen big data
erfordert wie quellenkritik und diese
big quellenkritik geht dann eben auch
nicht nur im einzelfall ich kann das
nicht 184.000 mal die echtheit eines
solchen retreats überprüfen sondern ich
muss dann auch für diese quellenkritik
automatisierbare verfahren mir überlegen
und ich sehe darin dann tatsächlich die
synthese aus diesen beiden sind
verheiratung seines todes ist oracle
racing und des computational thinking es
durchaus noch ist der hermeneutik oder
das des trainings in dem dann auch die
das wechselspiel zwischen geistes- und
naturwissenschaften ich wehre mich
weigere mich informatik
naturwissenschaften zu bezeichnen aber
es geht vor allem um die methodische
sichtweise im kontext stellt männerteams
neu neu zu denken und wieder nur
abschließend die beiden klassiker gut
hier nachts reusen der geistes und
naturwissenschaften ja dann eher nach
dem wie der methodik unterscheidet würde
ich sagen die geisteswissenschaftler
werden dann in der tat
naturwissenschaftler
naturwissenschaftliche ohne selbst
naturwissenschaften zu werden und ohne
dass interpretativen das aus der
menschlichen erfahrung heraus geborene
zu verlieren
und zweitens wäre dann dilthey durchaus
zu bemühen der nachdem studien
gegenstand unterscheidet und eben die
äußerungen des menschlichen geistes
betrachtet daran wird sich auch nichts
ändern auch wenn sich der menschliche
geist zunehmend im digitalen verortet
fühlt und die menschlichen äußerungen
sich technisierten selbst sind eher eine
frage ob selbst also von algorithmen
verfasste gedichte darunter gefasst
werden müssen muss man diskutieren denke
ich aber sie sind auch für mich das
gegenteil eigentlich von natur und
rassistische fantasien muss man hier
gegen der stelle sind vielleicht nicht
weiter reden ja umgekehrt zum schluss
und das ist das schlusswort den
geisteswissenschaften sich also von
ihrer methode der naturwissenschaften
nähern wäre gegenwärtig zu wünschen dass
auch die naturwissenschaften
sozialwissenschaften
ein sich mehr noch öffnen für eine
interpretativen kritik und sozusagen
auch ein stückweit naturwissenschaften
und ingenieurswissenschaften wo ich die
informatik jetzt eher dazu zählen würde
geisteswissenschaftlicher werden zu
lassen vor allem bei hochrisiko
technologien wozu ich jetzt oder
gentechnologie atomkraft aber künstliche
intelligenz zählen würde wäre das aus
meiner sicht sehr zu wünschen und genau
das meiner meinung nach ist die
schnittstelle zwischen diesen zwei
welten wie klose ja mal bezeichnet hat
und das ist aufgabe der digital
humanities